was geht ab usa max und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem video ich werde
heute war ich heute abend beim
geburtstag von sturm waffe bin einen
kuchen zusammen mit macken und wird es
euch zeigen
so ist allen m&m kit cars kuchen geben
mit viel schokolade schon zwei mal
gemacht jetzt
hmm
a
aha
das war's dann ja schon von dem video
wir waren da noch bei der party aber ich
hab keine kamera mitgenommen und es war
echt cool oder abend nochmal noch mal
alles gute story wenn du das siehst
und ja das war jetzt mal ganz anders um
mit viel musik wenig reden und kuchen
gut oder fahrzeug gefallen wenn ja dann
erst mal wenn ihr sagt voll blöd
schreibt auch in die kommentare warum
und ja dann bis zum nächsten mal